If you can't afford
your medication,
AstraZeneca
may be able to help.
>> Tucker: THE LEFT WASN'T
GOING TO LET IG'S REPORT GO
UNANSWERED.
EARLIER TODAY NEW YORK
ATTORNEY GENERAL BARBARA
UNDERWOOD ANNOUNCED NEW
LAWSUIT AGAINST THE TRUMP
FOUNDATION IN NEW YORK.
THE SUIT SEEKS TO DESOLVE
THE ORGANIZATION AND BAN
TRUMP AS WELL AS HIS THREE
CHILDREN FROM SERVING ON ANY
NONPROFIT.
DONALD TRUMP JR. IS ONE OF
THE PEOPLE TARGETED BY THAT
LAWSUIT AND HE JOINS US
TONIGHT.
DONALD TRUMP JR., THANKS FOR
JOINING US.
>> GOOD TO BE WITH YOU,
TUCKER.
HOW ARE YOU?
>> Tucker: I'M DOING GREAT.
BEFORE I ASK YOU ABOUT THE
SUIT OF THE NONPROFIT.
LET ME GET YOUR TAKE ON THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL REPORT YOU
SAW TODAY.
>> PRETTY INCREDIBLE.
I LOOK AT THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL HR AT MAJOR
CORPORATION, RIGHT?
THEY'RE NOT REALLY THERE TO
PROTECT THE INDIVIDUALS.
THEY ARE THERE TO PROTECT
THE CORPORATION.
>> AS DAMNING AS IT WAS.
>> IT PROBABLY DOESN'T GO
FAR ENOUGH AS IT RELATES TO
WHAT WAS REALLY GOING ON.
I THINK REAL AMERICA, AND
WHAT I HAVE BEEN SAYING FOR
WEEKS AND LAST TIME I WAS ON
WITH YOU, REAL AMERICA SEES
WHAT'S GOING ON HERE.
THEY SEE THAT THESE PHONY
PLAYERS AT THE TOP OF THE
FBI, NOT THE RANK AND FILE.
NOT THE BOOTS ON THE GROUND.
THE GUYS DOING THE REAL
WORK.
THEY SAID THESE LAWYERS THAT
NEVER WENT THROUGH THOSE
THINGS, HAD NEVER STARTED
DOWN AT THE BOTTOM.
THESE LAWYERS AT THE TOP
WERE TRYING TO INFLUENCE AN
ELECTION AND THEN UNDERMINE
A PRESIDENCY.
I LOOK AT JAMES COMEY.
IT'S LIKE THE LIBERAL
VERSION OF A SORORITY
SISTER.
LIKE IT'S PRETTY RIDICULOUS
AT THIS POINT.
WHEN I SEE WHAT'S GONE ON, I
THINK I SEE WHAT EVERYONE
ELSE IN AMERICA IS SEEING
AND THEY SHOULD BE
DISGUSTED.
>> Tucker: IF YOU ARE A
RIGHT OF CENTER PERSON NOT
YOU SPECIFICALLY ANY PERSON
AND YOU WERE CAUGHT UP IN AN
FBI INVESTIGATION, WOULDN'T
YOU WANT TO KNOW THAT THE
MAN IDENTIFIED AS FBI LAWYER
NUMBER TWO WASN'T ON YOUR
INVESTIGATION?
>> I THINK THAT WOULD BE
KIND OF IMPORTANT.
>> Tucker: WHY DON'T WE KNOW
HIS NAME AND SHOULDN'T WE
KNOW HIS NAME.
>> THAT'S WHAT I DON'T
UNDERSTAND.
ALL OF THIS STUFF GOING ON.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE STUFF
AND I HAVE TALKED ABOUT IT
WITH YOU ON YOUR SHOW.
THE STUFF I HAVE GONE
THROUGH OVER THE LAST 18
MONTHS, WHETHER IT BE ABOUT
THE RUSSIA INVESTIGATION.
IT'S THE BIGGEST DEAL 25
HOURS OF TESTIMONY IN FRONT
OF CONGRESS.
HILLARY CLINTON DOES 10 FOR
BENGHAZI AND, GUESS WHAT?
WHEN SHE AND THE DNC TEAM UP
TO PAY A FOREIGN AGENT TO
WORK WITH RUSSIA TO COMPILE
A FAKE DOSSIER AND SPEND
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO DO
THIS THING, ALL OF WHICH HAS
BEEN DEBUNKED.
NONE OF IT PROVEN.
CHASING THIS THING FOR TWO
YEARS.
NOTHING.
LITERALLY NOTHING HAPPENS.
SO I THINK IT JUST SLOWS THE
FLAGRANT DOUBLE STANDARD.
IF YOU ARE EVEN CENTER LET
ALONE RIGHT OF CENTER YOU
WOULD BE GETTING THE SAME
THING.
IF YOU ARE THE UBER LEFT,
YOU CAN GET AWAY WITH AND DO
WITH WHATEVER YOU WANT
BECAUSE THERE IS NO
ACCOUNTABILITY THERE.
I THINK REAL PEOPLE, AGAIN,
ARE STARTING TO SEE IT THEY
SHOULD BE DISGUSTED.
>> Tucker: SO
>> Tucker: NEW YORK ATTORNEY
GENERAL ANNOUNCED A SUIT
AGAINST THE CLINTON
FOUNDATION FOR -- I'M SORRY,
I GOT THAT WRONG AGAINST THE
TRUMP FOUNDATION.
>> RIGHT.
>> Tucker: AND YOU ARE NAMED
IN IT.
>> OF COURSE.
>> Tucker: WHAT'S YOUR
REACTION TO THAT.
>> LISTEN, IT'S NONSENSE.
IN THE END THIS IS A
CHARITABLE THAT WAS FUNDED
50% BY MY FATHER'S OWN MONEY
TO GO INTO GOOD DEESDZ.
IT'S SOMETHING THAT ERIC
SNEIDERMAN BEFORE HE WENT
DOWN IN A BALL OF FLAMES AS
ONE OF THE LEADERS OF THE
ORIGINAL ME TOO MOVEMENT,
YOU KNOW, WAS WORKING ON FOR
YEARS WHERE IS HE RIGHT NOW?
HE COULDN'T FOLLOW THROUGH.
THEY DO THIS ON THE DAY THE
IG REPORT TO BE ABLE TO
DOMINATE THE NEWS CYCLE.
GUESS WHAT?
MOST OF THE MEDIA WILL CARRY
BAGGAGE AND RUN WITH IT LIKE
IT'S A BIG THING.
IT REALLY ISN'T.
THIS IS A MONEY THAT WENT TO
GOOD AND CHARITABLE CAUSES.
HALF OF WHICH WAS FUNDED
ZERO EXPENSE RATIO.
DIDN'T HAVE EMPLOYEES.
WASN'T SENDING PEOPLE ON
G-5S ALL OVER THE WORLD LIKE
THE CLINTON FOUNDATION AT
90% EXPENSE RATIO.
THAT'S THE STANDARD AND THE
DOUBLE STANDARD BY WHICH WE
HAVE TO LIVE AND WE'LL KEEP
DOING THAT AND KEEP
FIGHTING.
WE WILL DO WHAT WE HAVE TO
DO.
BUT I THINK WHAT MY FATHER
IS DOING IS DOING AN AMAZING
JOB IN WASHINGTON, D.C.
HE IS SHOWING THIS FLAGRANT
DOUBLE STANDARD.
IS HE HIGHLIGHTING IT TO THE
PEOPLE.
THEY ARE SEEING IT.
THEY ARE FED UP.
AND THEY ARE WATCHING HIM
WIN DESPITE ALL OF THE
NOISE.
DESPITE ALL OF THE
OBSTRUCTION.
DESPITE ALL OF THE HYSTERIA
ABOUT ANYTHING THAT DONALD
TRUMP IS.
I MEAN, I WATCHED LAST WEEK
COMING FROM SINGAPORE AND
WATCHING ALL THESE PEOPLE.
THERE ARE PEOPLE ON THE LEFT
I ALMOST FEEL AS THOUGH THEY
WERE HOPING FOR A NUCLEAR
WAR BECAUSE THEN THEY COULD
SAY SEE, TRUMP FAILED.
IT'S REALLY RIDICULOUS,
TUCKER.
IT'S GONE TOO FAR.
>> Tucker: SO JUST TO GO
BACK TO THE SUIT.
I JUST WANT TO GET MY HEAD
AROUND IT.
IS THE IMPLICATION OR THE
CLAIM THAT YOU GOT RICH
BECAUSE YOU'RE NAMED IN IT,
THAT YOU GOT RICH BY YOUR
AFFILIATION WITH A
NONPROFIT?
DID YOU GET RICH.
>> I'M NOT SURE WHAT THE
CLAIM IS THE CLAIM IS THERE
IS SOMEHOW MISMANAGEMENT.
IN THE END THERE WERE NO
SALARIES PAID.
THERE IS NO EXPENSE.
THERE ARE NO PAID MEMBERS OF
THIS THING.
WE'RE SITTING THERE AS
ESSENTIALLY A BOARD TO SEE
THAT THE MONEY THAT HE IS
PUTTING IN THERE IS GOING
OUT TO OTHER CHARITABLE
CAUSES.
THAT'S ALL IT IS.
THIS ISN'T THE CLINTON
FOUNDATION WHERE THEY ARE
TAKING MONEY FROM FOREIGN
GOVERNMENTS WHO ARE THEN
GIVING TO THEIR FRIENDS TO
FLY AROUND ON G-5S FOR
PROJECTS THAT NEVER
MATERIALIZE.
YOU KNOW, IT'S REAL A LOT
DIFFERENT.
YOU CAN SEE A LIST OF ALL
THE CHARITIES I WENT.
TO SAY HALF OF THEM ARE
VETERANS CHARITIES.
>> Tucker: TO BE CLEAR, YOU
NEVER TOOK A SALARY.
>> I HAVE NEVER TAKEN A CENT
FROM IT, NO.
NEITHER ABOUT D. MY BROTHER,
DID MY SISTER AND NEITHER
DID MY FATHER.
>> Tucker: I'M EVEN MORE
CONFUSED.
>> AS AM I.
WE ARE USED TO IT BY NOW.